salem in new york salem in l.a salem in
san francisco say you live in chicago
say you live in any place and you say
there's no i don't care if people are
living in florida i don't care people
living in texas i don't care if they're
going to tennessee anywhere i am not
leaving this state perfect if that's you
there's two things you have to keep in
mind specifically for those of you that
have no plans of leaving your state or
your country now i'm going to make my
argument to you if it makes sense and i
get you thinking give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel so let's get
right into it last week i'm in l.a i'm
giving a speech at los hotel in santa
monica there's 400 people in the
audience and i opened up the speech
right off the bat i hit the stage i
asked this question i said how many of
you
have no plans of leaving the state of
california the next three to five years
and people are kind of startled by that
question so no one's really
participating i said let me ask this
question one more time there's a lot of
things that's going on right now and i'm
asking you a specific question how many
of you love your state so much that you
have no plans of leaving the state of
california the next three to five years
you saw 70 70 of hands that went up i
said perfect no problem i said how many
of you have plans of leaving the state
of california already looking at
different places based on what happened
the last 12 to 24 months you see 30
percent well that's a pretty big number
but he's a 30 raiser and saying yeah
we're kind of looking to see where we're
gonna go gonna go next i said no problem
i said today i just want to talk to the
people that want to stay in the state of
california they said great i said if
you're staying the state of california
here's what you're saying you're okay
with having the highest gas prices in
america you're okay with having a all in
taxes state gas sales you have the
highest amongst everybody in america
you're okay with high taxes you're okay
with high crime you're okay with high
homelessness you're okay with high
regulation you're okay with high control
i think they're about to go on masks
again on this friday la you're okay with
all of that are you still okay with all
of this kind of them looking to the left
i said it's totally fine if you're
you're still okay with that they're like
yes so perfect if you still are planning
to stay in the state of california let
me tell you two things you need to be
ready for what's that
last night i had dinner with my
entertainment lawyer in l.a at
crustaceans this is when i'm giving a
speech it was the night before
i said my lawyer michael let's call him
he says to me says patrick i bought a
house in van nuys
it's like right by toluca lake van nuys
he said i bought this place it's less
than two thousand square feet the house
should be six seven hundred thousand
dollars it just sold for 1.8 million
dollars i said what are you talking
about he says it's only three bedrooms
and it's sold for 1.8 it says i'm a
lawyer okay fine maybe i can afford it
how is somebody supposed to buy that
house i don't understand it i said 1.8
million is 1.8 million dollars
so okay how many guys got a family with
two or three kids and husband and wife
living together they raised their hands
it's great
so two thousand square foot house three
bedroom two bath 1.8 million dollars i
said what does it take to buy 1.8
million dollar house i asked one of the
realtors they get up they said we need
to put 10 down which is what 180. i said
great i said how many of you here have
180 000 in savings to put it down pimp
said don't answer that but just think
about it how many middle-income families
have 180 k to put on a down payment of a
house they don't raise their hands i
said okay fine so you got 1.62 million
dollars that you're financing
i said what's the average mortgage
payment on today's rates 5.7 i think it
just went up right now while i'm talking
to another three quarters of a basis
point i said what's the payment on a you
know 1.6 million dollar house at six
percent she says around 12 12 000
principal insurance tax everything
included
i said is that twelve thousand dollars a
month pre-tax money or after tax money
everybody's kind of like quiet they said
after tax money that's a perfect so to
net twelve thousand dollars in the state
of california what do i need to make
pre-tax to keep 12k she says around 20
000 40 taxes you keep 12 i said no
problem so i need to make 20 000 to
afford to pay 12 000 payment on a house
that's barely 2 000 square feet and it's
three bedroom two bath yes no problem i
said historically it's been said
whatever mortgage payment you're making
it should be about a third of your
income so if twenty thousand dollars is
a third of my income what should my
income be
and she says sixty thousand dollars a
month so so what's 60 times 12 they said
720. i said great i said how many of you
here your job's going to pay you 720 the
next 6 12 24 months you see everybody
laughing i said i'm actually not
laughing i'm actually being very serious
how many of you have a family you have
wife you have kids you have husbands you
have all this stuff going on
how soon will your current job pay you
720 per year in the state of california
because you said you want high taxes you
said you want high gas prices you said
you want the most expensive real estate
you said you want high crime high
homelessness you want to stay here i
didn't tell you to stay here you want to
stay here and they're all quite i said
now same people that i asked a question
from you how many of you make less than
six figures
70 of hands go go up
i said great of those of you that said
you have no plans of leaving the state
of california how many of you guys are
now open-minded to it
you see a quarter no joke a quarter said
i kind of have to start looking i said
because you either going to palmdale
lancaster or you got a couple options
that are out
in like the open without good education
without any good security or you got to
figure out a way to do something with
your income
so they said so what's the solution if
you're going to stay here you have to
know your economics meaning what kind of
money you need to make because you
cannot do it making 50 80 grand per year
in the state of california you can do it
in other states you cannot do it in the
state unless if you're living in the
buildings you cannot do it in the state
that you're in number one is economics
number two is figure out politics what
do you mean by politics
i said if we're living in the land of
the free and home of the brave start
being free and start being brave and
push back on why do we have the highest
gas prices specifically gas taxes why do
we have the highest taxes statewide why
do we have high crime why do we have
high homelessness why do you have all
this other stuff why ask why and get
involved and either make the politicians
change by the way you vote or get behind
somebody or eventually get involved in
politics but you're not going to be able
to do it with you sitting around saying
oh i love my state it's so awesome the
beach is great the weather is great the
earthquake is fantastic i love the
sports teams i love all this other stuff
oh my god babe life is so hard paying
all the bills man it's hard my kids
can't go to private school and if i
lived in another state you know the kids
could have gone to a private school but
i love california who cares if they
don't go to private school it's okay
they can go to a public school because i
love my state state and i'm willing to
pay all the high taxes
stop
you got a family your kids are relying
on you to make the right choices and you
the 20 year old virgin older of what you
are today is also relying on you to make
the right choices and fyi to those you
guys that are extremely loyal and you're
saying i'll never leave the state of
california i'll never leave illinois
i'll never leave these people that are
leaving our cowards really yes huh okay
question for you
did your
great-great-grandparents were they born
here
how many lineage up do i need to go
until we can find somebody in your
lineage that chose to leave their
country to come here to give you a
better life why did they do it were they
cowards were our parents cowards my
parents left do i call my parents
cowards or am i grateful for the fact
that they left iran and went to germany
at a refugee camp and eventually ended
up being here moral the story is the
foul one
if your state doesn't know that there's
a possibility of you leaving they will
keep gassing you they will keep raising
taxes on you they will keep doing
everything to you because you keep
saying i'm not going to leave because of
the beach
make a decision for you and your family
if you're staying make more money get
into politics if not leave the state and
go to a different place like many other
people have to protect their futures
that's your choice now if you're
watching this and this video is being
shared with like oh my god you hear what
pat said about california he called us
out he called us and shared with each
other but if my argument got you
thinking this much give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and share it
with everybody else you know in your
state that may also get pissed off and
let them see what they say about this
they'll comment below i'll read the
comments i totally disagree what he has
to say no problem i welcome it i want a
good debate i want a good conversation
if you want to watch a couple other
videos i did one video titled 10 reasons
why you should consider moving to
another state and 10 reasons why i moved
to the state of florida take care
everybody bye